if we had to ban twitter i'd be on board
i'd be like
government come in and just take
everyone's phone including mine yeah
list assignments oh i will gladly give
up oh
it's it's a horrible horrible thing it's
an example i think twitter is an example
of
why direct direct democracy doesn't work
it is literal mob rule on that site yeah
and it's just
people screaming as loud as possible and
saying the stupidest things
and that's what the world would be like
without this like system
heaven forbid we got rid of the
electoral college and twitter
represented what actually
won yeah well what what do you think
the i guess social media in general but
specifically twitter what effect do you
think that has had
on the progressive left people like aoc
yeah it's made them absolutely insane
look at bernie sanders
he's been like you know when i think of
politics in this country
you have like the left and the right and
donald trump is like sitting on a stump
in like kind of center right position
and he's flicking you know
a little bread at the birds and he's
just sitting there and he's like i'm
over here because everybody's sitting
there we're gonna build the wall it's
gonna be great
and then bernie was next to him but then
bernie was in a car just driving left
and just kept going yeah and now he's
not even in the room with anybody he's
just gone
bernie sanders originally was like and
the free trade agreements
we need border security you know uh open
border is a right-wing proposal
it's because hillary cut his brakes he
can't stop the car he just kept going
well i don't want to blame her but the
dnc cut his brain yeah but he's still
there
i don't i don't know i i think i think
it's because
they're a pr they're eating their own
refuse the the far left
is lovely imagery it's like human
centipede but like instead of instead of
one line it's a circle where they're all
stitched together you know
so so what happens is uh
and i've explained this quite a bit if
it can if so if someone on the right
steps out of line even a little bit
banned instead yeah so all that's left
are these very
like you know clean cut for the most
part moderate conservative types on
social media
you know you miley annopolis alex jones
lore loom are all removed
from twitter so they're not part of the
conversation anymore now you have
jack basobic and like will chamberlain
and they're very
you know for all the criticisms that
people give jack it's he's still
very just kind of i don't the right word
is um
to me he's just you know mainstream
conservative i don't well
i want to say kind of like downtone not
bombastic not screaming
you know you're getting like i hereby
think this is important for this reason
it's kind of like okay i get it
but the left is allowed to say whatever
they want it's a private company
i worked at my i worked at mines for a
long time i co-founded the company and
worked as an admin
you get total control of who you want to
ban within reason
of how you interpret the code how you
interpret it so think about what happens
so jack dorsey who literally donated
what 10 million dollars to ibra mexicany
that that
you know basically that blacks i don't
know what you want to call him but he's
he's essentially you know
he is a supremacist yeah he's he or he's
a segregationist i guess yeah that's
called amy connie barrett
you know a bunch of really awful things
because of her kids but anyway jack
dorothy donates to that guy
so then he allows the fringe of the
fringe
and so because there's no breaks on the
left
in social media they're just going full
speed
mach 7 to the left whereas conservatives
are being held where they are because if
they step out of line they'll get banned
right
so that that turns someone like liberal
tim poole into a conservative because
they just keep going further and further
left
well i mean i think the whole with a
whole twitter thing and facebook as well
youtube all of these tech platforms i
think we are
if we're not already there we are
entering an age where we're going to be
a technocracy right
and what i don't understand is right now
in the us and really i think most
democracies there are campaign finance
finance laws
and restrictions about how you can
advertise on these social media
like platforms because they recognize it
is campaigning
so how can you tell me that you know
donald trump
posting an ad onto facebook or whatever
that's political activism needs to be
declared and monitor
all that but facebook can ban whoever
they want flat out control whatever
stories flat out and we can't do
anything about that that makes no sense
facebook just banned 216 trump ads
because he was talking about
a bunch of the ads were like joe biden
will increase the amount of refugees
coming in this country
a very serious issue that people are
concerned with if you are concerned
about it you know increasing
immigrants and refugee refugees in this
country it doesn't mean you're racist
facebook banned them because they think
that's racist they have a rule against
telling people that they're in danger
due to
you know other people based on national
origin or whatever and it's
arbitrary wait so is does that mean that
democrats aren't allowed to tell people
that
the russians are trying to fix their
election it does but of course they'll
get away with it yeah and they'll get to
do whatever they want
i mean and and boy are they really
pushing that russia garbage
they are and you know what's funny back
baby i'm old enough
where i can remember that gosh when mitt
romney was running against barack obama
he actually named
russia as the biggest threat to the
united states and all the liberals at
the time were laughing
yeah this is the cold war grandpa and
then you know just a couple
several years later here we are and
they're trying to make and don't get me
wrong i'm not saying that like
russia is amazing in terms of track
record for human rights and i'm also not
saying they're not trying to influence
things but they're really making them
out to be the boogeyman
this is a really good example of why
service guarantees citizenship as an
idea
because right now you have these low i
call them low information belligerence
so that's like a dude i know in chicago
who's always retweeting stuff and it's
the funniest thing because i'm like
bro i know you you sit around making
sourdough bread in your apartment
you're you're not paying attention at
all to any of this you're seeing a spicy
hot take from someone that you don't
understand and you're hitting retweet
you're not going to vote i know you're
not going to vote but you're pushing
these
unhinged busted ideas because it's
tribal
and then you're sitting there going like
i'm
and then what and then they and then
they have the nerve to criticize me dude
i read nothing but news all day every
day for hours
and then we i do four hours of content
on it i'm not saying i know everything
in the world but i'm pretty sure
i know a bit more than these random
people who think they're they're smart
so you get a bunch of people who have no
idea what's going on who for tribal
reasons are like
we wanna we wanna own the cons so we're
gonna go vote against our own interests
while simultaneously believing the trump
supporters are voting against their own
interests
that's that's one of the funniest things
too about this whole cycle is like
someone commented on one of my
threads being like trump has lied to you
he has
you know told you to live recklessly and
now you've all been convinced the whole
time while he's getting all the best
treatment in the world it's like the
kovad thing
like he told you to drink bleach while
he gets medicines like
except he never said that yeah like joe
biden said on the debate stage why don't
you inject some bleach
and then trump responded that was
sarcastic trump you didn't even say to
inject bleach just
man trump was really off his game huh
yeah but it's like i don't care
what these people don't realize is the
best example
of the left having no idea what's going
on is the proud boys hashtag
you saw this yes i did so there was 500
000 tweets
of mostly lgbt people and it was photos
of like
gay couples saying we're proud boys and
the actual proud boys didn't care
yeah and they never did and they didn't
even use the hashtag so i guess like
the leader of the proud boys issued a
statement saying we have gay members
we're totally cool with this
like i don't understand what the point
is they don't care
the journalists were actually saying
after the debate don't interview the
proud boys don't give them press and i'm
like
the real reason they're saying that is
because then they'd be forced to
interview a black man
and ask him why he's a white supremacist
and americans would be like huh
what who's this what but that but that's
that's that's the name of the game
don't talk don't report the news don't
tell me what's really going on
when i when i started uh uh doing like
my daily youtube stuff after i left
fusion
i was going to sweden because you had
this right-wing narrative
of you know all this all this violence
in sweden and donald trump was like you
see what's going on last night in sweden
so i said i'm gonna go i got hit up by a
bunch of vice news journalists saying
don't do it
and i was like why not and they're like
because they're they're lying and i was
like who's lying the conservatives
then you'd go and you'd see that i was
like great i'll go and prove that
they're lying and they're like no don't
do it donate your money to charity and i
was like
what i was really confused i was like
dude i worked with you like a year ago
you know i travel around the world
covering news whenever there's a big
story
why wouldn't i go to sweden it sounds
too i was like i was i was literally
there three months before
i had ice cream walking around it was
totally fine i was in mama and i was
like i don't understand why
i'm getting berated all of a sudden this
was when like
i guess i i think the culture war
started and i was like off doing my
thing you know i went to like japan it
was in fukushima and just filming
documentaries and my own business
and then all these people were going
insane and people i had worked with who
were like
supposedly normal journalists lost their
minds and they were like for the sake of
our tribe don't you dare report the news
i was like huh that makes no sense to me
but those people are gonna vote now
they're going to vote after they're
telling me not to report the news
they're telling others not to report the
news
now you have a bunch of low information
people who think they're smarter than
everyone and they're voting
i think uh there's a xenophobic uh
tinge in the united states that's just
it's just prevalent in our culture
like i always grow up what do you mean
by that i was told south america is
dangerous
i was like oh and so i believed it and
then i went to south america
in the jungle in in chile where they
don't have local police they only have
i went there and it's not i mean yeah it
is
the united states is great you know our
local law enforcement is killer it's the
best
it's not the word i should use the law
awesome having a local law enforcement
protecting you from the federal level or
from the state level from the federal
level is
amazing like in chile it's only national
cops so if you
mess up one place the whole country
you're you're a criminal
uh you don't have local protection but
it's not
something to fear and unless you go
there you wouldn't know that because our
whole culture is like
don't leave you're safe here so relative
are we are any of us
qualified to vote except for the ones
that dig deep well
i think a lot of people would say no
frankly
there are people out there who who are
very disillusioned and they just want to
kind of return to
i mean i've even i've even seen people
like
advocate for monarchies right now like a
constitutional monarchy just because
they're so
disillusioned with things i'm not doing
that but yeah i mean
a lot of people feel the exact same way
they think everyone the system is broken
uh you know votes can't be trusted and
even if they could be do people
have enough information to vote it it's
it's really scary and i
there's no good answer yeah there's no
perfect system because if you get
uh let's say you have a monarchy and you
have a great leader
then the country is going to work really
really well but then they have a kid and
the kids
a dick and then the country you know
doesn't do well
or you get you get these ideologues who
think they're smarter than the
collective
you know computational power of the
human mind decentralized
so like a really good example of that
would be like hugo chavez or fidel
castro or any other communist
where it's like the capitalistic system
we have is
decentralized um
apportionment of resources so you have
each individual deciding what they need
and when they want it and then people
freely trade and the system just
operates in a decentralized network
the communists think one individual can
calculate
better than millions of centralized
systems which they can't
right and so then everything ends up
breaking shortages
right lines so the the key is like
i really think the united states is the
best form of government we we've seen
this planet so far
you have three branches you've got your
monarch and the executive
but there's limits and they have to be
voted in then you have your direct
democracy which is congress which is
terrible and everyone hates but
at least it's you know by you know
region and then you have the council of
elders so it's like three different
types of of government combined that are
constantly yelling at each other
the problem we have is it was impossible
for the founding fathers
to cover every loophole so i was
watching this new video by cgp grade you
guys know cgp grays
great youtube channel and he was talking
about the supreme court and it was very
nonpartisan it's very awesome
it was explaining that there's something
called a recess appointment
that if congress is in recess the
president can appoint a supreme court
justice
until they come back to vote but what
they they do something called pro forma
sessions where they basically walk in
and go all you know all rise there's no
one there okay we're done for the day
everyone have a nice day that way
they're still
technically in session so it's it's
clearly
a manipulation on what the constitution
was supposed to allow
but it's allowed so trump should be able
or and obama should have been able to
say merrick garland is temporarily being
put on the court
until senate comes back and then votes
yeah or nay
but instead they just come back it's
like every every fourth day
because you're allowed to resist for
three days you're allowed to take a
break for three days otherwise it's
considered a recess
so on the fourth day they come in and
they say all duties
you know relegated to this individual
and then they walk out and then no one
shows up
yeah so it's clearly broken how we fix
it
i don't know have you guys heard of the
national initiative
it was a concept to create a fourth
branch of government
mike revell uh senator alaskan senator i
think he was
yeah so it would make like uh every
state would have a representative
and then each of those representatives
would receive data from their
constituents and then they'd be able to
pass laws so basically like
the people's version of the legislation
and then we'd be able to pass laws into
the senate
but that's literally what the house is
well but it would give the population
the ability to write laws send it to the
representative and then the national
initiative
that's still technically allowed like i
mean nothing's stopping
any citizen from sending things to the
representative but
then we have to rely on on congress to
do it like you say they're corrupt as
all get out
it's not it's not that they're corrupt i
think they're corrupt
yeah but the problem with congress and
their low approval is likely due to the
fact that
if one person represents one district
they clearly don't care about all the
other districts
so if you have like aoc right and she
wins and
she did really really well in her
primary you've got a ton of people in
that district who love her
everyone else in the country hates her
right not everybody but the majority
so then what's going to happen is you're
going to ask everyone in the country how
do you feel about aoc and most of them
are going to say we don't like her
because she rep yeah she represents one
district
so it's very likely that every member of
congress will have a low
national approval rating right so then
congress gets an overall really low
approval rating
we were kind of talking about this
before the show but that's exactly why
i'm at least in favor of
balkanization or at the very least more
decentralization because i think the way
the founding fathers imagined the
federal government
ruling over you know all these different
states operating somewhat
autonomously was a good idea right i
think if people in california want to do
x y or z
they should be able to and if you don't
like it you can move to somewhere more
free but right now the size of the
federal government
i mean in canada as well it's so big
that you have these people
in california or in quebec and ontario
like
they vote on legislation that affects
everyone in the country
and that i don't think that's fair and i
think either you know let's bring back
the concept of city-states
or shrink down the federal government
and let more of these issues be decided
on a local level so the people
who are voting for these laws who want
to live under them they're not affecting
the ones who don't
and so would you set up like sunset
clauses and all current laws
so that yeah i mean i think it would
need to be something
like that because otherwise i mean there
like the amount of laws that are
on the books it's it's literally an
oppressive amount
yeah and they never go away right it's
like we have a tendency towards creating
more laws and not getting rid of them
yeah we talked about this before there's
like ridiculous laws like you can't take
a bath on sundays in massachusetts or
something
because it was like back then it made
sense they just left it yeah they just
leave it but then like no one enforces
it
yeah but then you so there's actually
something really interesting i was
reading about uh
new york there's this funny story where
a black cop went to central park
and started giving out public drinking
tickets to
couples having picnics and drinking wine
and he got in trouble for it
and all these people were like like i
was drinking wine on my picnic why was i
being cited for public intoxication
and the cops said because the cops come
to my neighborhood and give out tickets
to the dudes drinking 40s on their stew
so you want to come to my neighborhood
give out tickets i'm going to come to
your hood and give out tickets
and so apparently it created this like
you know fiasco where the cop actually
got in trouble which
i think is bs because he was totally
right yeah he's nothing is right that's
that's a lie
i got tickets yeah you can't have it you
know we need to qualify wow
but i started reading about this and it
was funny apparently when they banned
public drinking in new york
it was because of homeless drunk people
and like vagrants
and some politicians said this law will
never be construed obviously this law
will never be construed to say that a
worker couldn't enjoy a beer with their
lunch and now quite literally you can't
have a beer with your lunch
yeah so it's like they write laws
thinking we know exactly what the point
of this law is
then two generations go by and it's like
i don't know it says no one's allowed to
drink so
yeah i mean that's the only debate over
like an originalist versus a textualist
um and i i'm not someone who thinks like
oh well this literally says
this so we can ignore the spirit of the
law but that's why i think you can't
really
you can't leave things up to
interpretation i think you should be as
specifically clear as possible and like
even this whole debate over the second
amendment
i mean we know from looking through
history what the founding fathers meant
i mean we have people saying oh well
they didn't mean weapons of war like
other merchant ships with cannons
actually at the time
private sears man you could have your
own warship it's pretty obvious what
they meant because it's not explicitly
written enough in these people's
opinions it's up for interpretation you
know those the original writing of the
second amendment was much more clear
it straight-up said something to the
effect of like even if you aren't
joining any kind of military service you
can still have a gun
yeah they should have left it they
should i wonder i think they didn't
because
it would have i guess band can strip
banned conscription
interesting and so they that was that
was something having to do with it but
the general idea was if somebody doesn't
want to join the military they're still
allowed to have guns
yeah they get rid of that and now the
left is going but it says a
well-regulated militia
yeah what does regulated mean what was
that what was the original concept
because i've heard some people say it
meant
regulated in the sense of they have
weapons that are clean and operable
i've read things saying that they were
you know the left
says it's regulated by the government
but the government wasn't that powerful
or encompassing back then there was no
like you could be off in the middle of
the woods there was no regulation over
you not nothing could be there were like
regulars were military exactly an
advanced form of a military crew i don't
know the definition exactly what
it was it was so i i've read some
arguments that it was a reference to
the stats having standard equipment a
regulated militia
they all had the same gun if one dropped
it you could pick it up and you knew how
to use it
yeah and so from that reading it was
a militia of people who have guns know
how to use them and they're up
and they're up to you know they're
they're working and functional is safe
is what we need for a free state
therefore everyone should be able to
have guns
but now they've changed it because the
left are you know textual it's like
no no regulated today oh so like if you
had an ar and i had a pistol
we're not regular i don't i don't know
exactly no the argument like that would
be that would still be the
the idea was that you were well equipped
the problem with the textualists is that
this this manipulation of the far left
changing definitions is that the
constitution could mean
the first amendment okay let's change
the definition of religion and now all
of a sudden you've changed the first
amendment
so if you're a textualist and you're
going by what it says based on what we
interpret the language today there's no
constitution at all
right and i i i agree with that i think
isn't kavanaugh more of a textualist
i don't know yeah i think i i had read
that somewhere but yeah i mean i i
completely agree that that's
that's a problem and it's a slippery
thing to do yeah
i would say regarding militias that it's
important if we were going to like form
a militia that we all knew how to use
each other's weapons
well that's why everyone has standard
issue weapons well
in the military but like if we were
going to form a well-regulated militia
would be like i know how to use your
weapon your
so we're all trained with each other's
weapons in case you go down i can pick
your weapon up and know how to use it
and that hurts
i think i think the general idea of guns
is that that's it oh i thought the
sentence was just getting started no
that was it
is that what do you mean that's that
well i mean so
when uh 78 have you ever seen that movie
um what you call it the last samurai i
think with
tom cruise yeah basically like the the
americans go to japan and they're like
with these weapons you can take a random
dude and he can press the thing and then
boom you blow somebody up
it allowed them to have like to lower
the cost of training great warriors
the samurai had to go through all this
training and be the best of the best
raised from youth
now you just got a gun you know you
crank the lever and then you get some
random dude to do it and you're blowing
people up you win but you want to know
how to take it apart how to clean it
uh yeah i only wanted to load it look at
the mcdonald's method
ever have you seen the movie the founder
no have you seen the founder
it's a good movie it's about it's about
the the start of mcdonald's oh
and basically the idea was
each person in the mcdonald's only knew
how to do one simple thing
no one person could make the burger like
assembly line exactly yeah so it wasn't
regulated
your job is the lettuce your job is the
mayo and the mustard ketchup is the
ketchup and the mustard that's the more
efficient way to do that i mean in the
military is to to a point is like that
like you have one guy's the medic
yeah you have specialized everyone
trains with the grenade launcher
everyone trains with the app well to a
certain
point right i mean there are still
specialized role like if you're a radio
operator
you know the average person isn't gonna
be able to do your job like you are
right
it's like what is it the marine corps
like every marina rifleman or
infantryman or something like that yeah
is that it everyone is at least a
rifleman yeah well then
do you think that uh november 3rd the
united states is going to descend into
chaos fracture into multiple countries
and then uh you know someone's going to
fire off the nukes and the world's going
to blow up and then we're all dead well
you know what the interesting thing is
because 2020 has been such a terrible
year i mean i i
i'm ready for 2021 i'm like let's finish
it's like a roller coaster man it's fun
huh
oh i'm tired i'm very tired i'm tired
um i i was thinking about this like what
what probably will happen
is the most disruptive thing and i kind
of think the most disruptive thing for a
lot of people would be trump winning
so i do think that that's gonna happen
um and i think
you know the people on social media will
cry there will be riots
um you know liberal governors won't
accept help as
as kind of has been happening all this
summer but i think life will ultimately
go on
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you